here is a great local story that
involves a hometown rock band imagine
dragons came home tonight to give one
local high school a night to remember
sasha loftis was at bonanza high tonight
and sasha this was really huge for all
those kids
denise it definitely was everyone we
spoke with tonight was just truly happy
to be here many students here at bonanza
high school this was their first time
seeing imagine dragons in concert and
they say they're huge fans now those we
spoke with say they're also grateful the
band took the time to come home and
celebrate where it all started
a once-in-a-lifetime experience comes
home to bonanza high school
imagine dragons hit the stage friday
night playing for a select group of
students staff and a few lucky community
members i've never heard of such a thing
at any school so it's cool that we get
to experience it i'm able to have a
piece of bonanza up here on stage with
us so lead singer and las vegas native
dan reynolds led the charge to make this
happen at his alma mater it's part of
the walmart homecoming concert series
that's helping musical artists honor
where they came from they called me up
and said what do you think i said
absolutely
we want the imagine dragons here a few
of the 2005 graduates teachers were also
in attendance including his former coach
it's such an amazing feeling to see
somebody really follow through and
follow
what they've always wanted to do and be
extremely successful at it she and
others here say they're so proud to see
what he's accomplished and grateful the
band is willing to give back i feel
extremely lucky and i'm grateful that
you know they took the time to like come
down here with us providing these
magical moments they'll all remember
for decades to come i think this night
will probably stick with me forever
now another cool moment tonight bonanza
high school dancers a few of them were
able to take the stage with imagine
dragons for a couple songs just a great
opportunity for them now this entire
concert will also stream online on
september 7th we have more information
on our website if you'd like to check it
out then
8newsnow.com reporting live from bonanza
high school tonight sasha loftis 8 news
now